hi I'm Erik Bosse and the delightful
thor ragnarok kept him with Marvel's
tradition with two very interesting
post-credit scenes I'm gonna break down
what they were and more importantly what
they mean for the future of the MCU and
the upcoming Avengers infinity war but
first obviously spoilers ahead for these
scenes and the movie Thor Ragnarok and
the unreleased infinity war trailer that
came out last summer like I think you
should know whether or not it's safe to
watch this video for you just take
responsibility for you on clicking okay
here we go as mentioned there were two
bonus scenes that play during the
credits one with Thor and Loki setting
up the future films and a second shorter
funny one with the Grandmaster Jeff
Goldblum's character let's actually
tackle that second one first
so after being left behind on the trash
planet of Sekar following Thor and
Hulk's escape the Grandmaster stumbles
out of his ship and runs into some very
angry residents a sacar he refers to an
earlier attempt to overthrow him as
leader Sekar nervously declaring the
revolution has been a huge success and
then he adds it's a tie
a kind of slide joke about how and
politics ties end up going to the runner
or rather the runner who's already in
charge
sure angry insurrectionists loved
hearing that but enough with the last
let's get to that warm nerdy middle
credit scene Thor and Loki have departed
Asgard on their new temporary spaceship
home and they set their destination as
Earth
Loki questions whether it's a good idea
for him to return there given his you
know attempted enslave the planet and
the Avengers the war doesn't have to
worry because he's you know really
popular there but then Thor gets cut off
by the arrival of a massive ship that
we've never seen before and then the
scene ominously cuts to black now given
what we know about Avengers infinity war
this is probably Thanos the super
powerful arch villain who's been lurking
in the cosmic shadows of MCU since the
Avengers this ship could actually be a
version of thanasis sanctuary starships
from the Marvel Comics it's kind of his
base of operations but we know from past
movies that sanctuary was the name given
to the asteroid field that he hangs out
in so we'll see if this gets a new name
the last time we saw thinness in the MCU
was in the post-credits scene of The
Avengers age of Ultron as he splits on
the Infinity Gauntlet to pick up where
past servants like Loki and Ronan failed
okay I'm gonna make some quick
predictions here for infinity war based
on other footage we've seen someone last
boiler warning earlier in ragnarök loki
goes into Odin's vault to retrieve
Searchers crown so they can defeat hella
while in there he stops and lingers on
the tesseract the Infinity stone that he
previously promised to deliver to Thanos
in the infinity war footage that was
played behind closed doors at d23 last
summer there's a quick shot of Loki
holding up the tesseract implying that
he stole it and that maybe he's offering
it to Thanos as a bargain actually if
this mysterious ship is Thanos it's
possible that Loki was the one who
summoned it another clip from the
infinity war footage showed Thor
floating through space smacking into the
guardians of the galaxy windshield we
could be looking at the aftermath of an
attack by Thanos which were starting to
see here maybe in this post credits
scene with Loki then be trained Thor in
leaving him floating in the cosmos
now of course Thor wasn't missing an eye
in that infinity war footage like he is
at the end of Ragnarok I'm guessing that
was to avoid spoiling the twist and
Ragnarok or it's possible that all the
d23 stuff was just test footage shot
special for fans and won't be in the
final cut of the film I don't know guys
it's getting harder and harder to
Sherlock this crap why do I even bother
because I have nothing better to do and
I need attention do you think Thor has
gotten too popular for the Avengers will
the success of Ragnarok outshine
infinity war when Thor returns to the
larger team personally I hope Thor's
inflated the ego and battle scars sets
up some alpha dog tension among him and
Stark and cats about time another dog
came into that fight comment down below
and tweet me your thoughts on thor
ragnarok a TA boss or followed new rock
stars on twitter at new rockstars for
updates other videos like this video
share it around and subscribe to new
rockstars more breakdowns of Marvel and
other stuff that you love and you can
help us make more videos like this by
contributing to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our donors especially Pony
Stark thanks for watching bye